[Music]
okay
we have another mibs hole
our favorite kind of reddit post please
i think
dude that's how i clean my [ __ ] oh my
dude again
is your hand okay you go like this right
like a periscope and a submarine
like a roto-rooter yeah yeah my
how far how far do you get in there are
you like first knuckles the first
knuckle the funny thing is
he fingers his [ __ ] and then when
jill tries to put a finger in there he
can't
it's too tight it closes up like
reflexes like good
best mechanisms if you just get high
enough and then you're like super
relaxed
it's never that relaxed it's got to be
his own finger because he's prepared for
it
my butthole has to take the hit i have
to put the bong on my butthole
yeah gross
how do you even make a butthole inhale
you gotta you gotta blow
do i mean people drink on their butthole
cbd oil if you just rub
cbd oil maybe it needs to be really
relaxed
numbing cream okay what's the article
i don't want to talk about this well
it's not an article it's the am i there
i'm an [ __ ] okay so it's titled
am i the [ __ ] for cleaning
poop off my female friend can you poop
my wife
off wait cleaning coop poop off strap in
all right here we go wait what ready
yeah so it says
i will try to make this short so here
goes it okay i am a 30 year old married
man
we recently had a party at our place for
some close friends after covet
seven of us total by different
circumstances we don't have much family
and we decided that we would be our
bubble of people
that we could see during coveted times
four women three guys
long story short we drank quite a bit
and everyone was planning at
crashing at our place no big deal
nothing unusual one girl there that
recently became
single drank a lot likely due to the
breakup
and passed out on the floor i moved her
onto the couch nera so we could continue
talking while monitoring her
didn't want her to choke or on puke or
something
well eventually she stirs rolls over and
reveals
that she has pooped herself down her
skirt and down her legs
also on my couch but it was a shitty
couch now it's a really shitty
that's what i'm saying i would have kept
them on the floor because i don't want
any puke on my couch
look on the floor she pooped her pants
she pooped on her skirt that she must
have been really drunk yeah everyone
laughed at laughs at first
then starts gagging the couple the
couples
basically say that's a sign the night is
over and they start going to their rooms
well i'm the lone hold out that we can't
just leave her covered in poop my wife
was too drunk to help and went to bed
i was conflicted because this was a
close friend so i did what i thought was
best
i grabbed baby wipes and cleaned her up
to be clear
i did not touch her vagina at all i did
clean the pores
so he left crap on her vagina i did
clean the poop off her butt and just
quickly ran a wipe through her butt
crack
parentheses i'm a nurse so i have a
super strong
gag reflex oh i slept on the couch next
to her just
in case i heard her choking on a
different couch next morning
everyone wakes up and comes to see their
friend covered
in poop well she's not anymore and
that's when it starts
i can't believe you did that that's
assault you basically groped her
are you serious my wife was no help
which hurt badly
and implied that i should have gotten
her to do it despite the fact that she
was way too drunk to help
i feel like my friends aren't messaging
me as much anymore and i'm being
excluded
today was a final straw when i looked at
my wife's phone and saw a group chat of
the girls
and one of my best friends suggested the
passed out girl file
a police report i don't know what to do
i'm so frustrated because i tried to do
the right thing
i'm a goddamn nurse cleaning people
cleaning poop off someone is so clinical
in practice it's almost routine at this
point
am i the [ __ ] wait so the girl that
pooped herself
she was also like oh my god you violated
me so then
no so then we're making her feel that
way so then he added more uh
at the end uh the girl who had the
accident was horribly embarrassed the
next day and left shortly after i didn't
harp on it because i was trying not to
embarrass her even as
everyone was calling me out i apologized
day of which in hindsight kind of makes
me look guilty or something
poor dude it's weird it's his place yeah
his house
him and his wife and he's also a nurse
yeah he's a he does that every day then
yeah but a lot of people that have no
connection to the medical world
don't see it the same way when they you
know
just they think by no means someone
should
touch that area or whatever and the wife
wasn't
like she was passed out drunk but she
knows that he's like a nurse and like
yeah like why would the nurse be
why would the wife be in the secret chat
against him that's so weird that's
that's kind of like my heartbeat really
shitty friends
and the wife does he have a history of
doing things
that's a good question yeah or history
of him and her also flirting too
yeah i think with this it's like
yeah you uh because it's scary times and
anyone can twist anything and like
think i think even though he's a nurse
next time or anyone
like unless it's like you get other
people and like to make sure that you're
not doing anything
improperly at least so they can have
like evidence or something he should
have had the couples there
yeah like he should have just put her in
the bathroom or something and just been
like all right you're gonna be in your
shitty clothes overnight
uh and yeah but then he was afraid that
she was gonna choke in her own vomit
because that happens like people die
getting [ __ ] drunk and then they
choke on their own vomit
i don't know dude without context if it
was just the facts i don't think he's an
[ __ ] i don't think he's an [ __ ]
but also why were the couples
so [ __ ] up they she [ __ ] on herself
and they go
oh i'm going to bed like that's some
shitty [ __ ] fastball
honestly like if that was my set of
friends everyone's
drunk trying to clean her up yeah
everyone's like oh [ __ ] she [ __ ] herself
hey get the [ __ ] paper
and then like you can see everyone yeah
and everyone's going
[Applause]
and they're [ __ ] like cleaning this
[ __ ] up well everyone's puking totally
or we all [ __ ] on ourselves to match
shirt yeah and then everything is done
and then they go all right you gotta
[ __ ] watch her and you go to sleep
so to me like the fact that all of the
couples
saw her [ __ ] herself and says i'm not
dealing with that
that is a group of [ __ ] up friends and
then also the way they're reacting like
how are you not [ __ ] using your
brains
uh who's the first thing is like oh she
should herself
all right i'ma let her sleep it off
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah
yeah i mean at least like even everyone
being drunk and [ __ ] it's like [ __ ]
throw her in the shower
turn on the water like just [ __ ]
rinse it off at least you guys are all
there working
yeah at least the girls well they're
just put their clothes on if they're too
drunk if everyone's really [ __ ] drunk
you just don't know everyone's just
stupid
i think the nurse is a huge factor it is
i was thinking about when you're in
casey had your
bachelor bachelorette party right me and
nadeem carried you guys in because you
guys are super drunk right
so i'm like if if you [ __ ] yourself
i'm like i'm not gonna try to wipe your
ass casey shoots himself
i'll probably wipe his ass we've both
been naked at a wee spa before but if it
was me and geo
bringing you guys in maybe she'll wipe
her ass maybe i'll wipe casey's ass
but if i think if i was a nurse then
maybe
i would i would wipe both asses because
you're also so desensitized to it it's
part of your job and you know how to
wipe adult ass i mean it's kind of like
similarly like when you were my trainer
like you would be like spotting me as
i'm doing squats and other people be
like that's inappropriate like
yeah yeah no i mean similarly like
you're a professional in that sense
obviously there's lots of realms of this
that are super
inappropriate but then you might as well
be like well the first thing was
inappropriate is she [ __ ] shot
herself
well she can't control that you you can
control how you drink though
right you know what i'm saying so it's
like
like she shot herself that you know if
you're a grown-ass adult and stuff like
that and you [ __ ] yourself
like your options at that point it's not
really about like this guy's sexually
whatever me it's like no you your [ __ ]
is on his couch
your [ __ ] is on his floor your shit's on
his couch you might die if you choke on
[ __ ] so then your death is on here
if she didn't share herself and he was
like oh let me just check
yeah yeah like if if she didn't oh yeah
then that'd be [ __ ] that'd be weird
but she literally shot herself i don't
think anyone's like
you they were all gagging but yeah but
like i don't think anyone would be like
how are you gonna be like oh you found
that sexual and you wanted to exactly
yeah cause he's gotta be a really
disgusting man to be turned on by that
he goes i'm glad everyone's
[ __ ] asleep now i can wipe her ass
yeah
as soon as i see conquer on a woman no
matter how hot she is i'm just like
you got cocka on your body girl would
you rather would you rather let's say
you [ __ ] yourself right
you pass out you don't know what's going
on would you rather wake up
right you still obviously got [ __ ]
stains but you're kind of clean it's
very embarrassing no matter what's
embarrassing and the whole room smells
like [ __ ]
or would you have to wake up in the same
spot but i didn't want to wipe you down
so i put a bunch of newspapers on you
and i put some kleenex right there and i
was like i hope when you wake up you get
it
no i'd be i dude i would rather get
cleaned
than deal with that because then you
never you don't know like what if i had
cuts on my legs or this is actually
something some someone commented
infections
they were like what if i had a cut on my
leg and like you get an infection
or something like that's even worse than
just [ __ ] quickly wiping it like i'll
deal with that embarrassment but
ultimately this man is a nurse like i'm
in his home like his wife is here like
other friends like we're all really
close [ __ ] friends to the point where
this is my
coven bubble like yeah i want to wake up
naked
you want to go naked no like if i [ __ ]
myself don't put the clothes back on me
just leave my cocker clothes outside and
[ __ ] put in the washer so when i wake
up naked they're like yeah your clothes
is in the washer thank god now i could
put on some fresh [ __ ] underwear but
it's different because you are a man
so like it would be like a different
like mentality if you're a woman
you wake up naked you might think like
something happened yeah for sure
all right well i mean like i can wake up
and think my friend rape me too
you know like i think it's it's pretty
normal like to think that if you're
if i i would assume that even for her
waking up even if she's clean
i don't think the first thing she's
thinking is like i got raped
you know also i mean
because okay this one time i had woken
up in a motel
with a man and i was like what the [ __ ]
just happened
i didn't feel my body as if it got
violated so i
to this day i believe that he was just
being a good person okay the back story
i was 16 i snuck out of my house we went
to a house party
i got really [ __ ] drunk and
apparently the whole time that i was
drunk because i had like flashes of when
i was
drunk um and i was telling him like oh
my god i can't go home i can't go home i
can't go home i'm so i'm way too drunk
like
i'm gonna get caught and so this guy he
was
a lot older too so he was the cousin of
my girlfriend and so he took
my friend home and then he was like well
[ __ ] i don't want you to get in trouble
you keep telling me not to take you home
so he ended up running like a motel at
the motel six
and he was on the chair when i woke up
and i i was in
the bed and i was like holy [ __ ] what
just happened he was like oh
don't worry like nothing happened like i
just wanted to make sure you were safe
and then like i was just like okay
there's my [ __ ] there
like okay yeah like everything's
everything and you know how much time
has passed
um i think we were there for like two or
three hours yeah but you're just too
[ __ ] drunk and then you
you passed out yeah like i knocked out
so by the time i woke up
it was like five a.m so like the sun was
barely coming up
and so he was just sleeping on the chair
yeah he was sleeping on the chair so i'm
like
okay good thing so yeah so
i mean like me being in that situation
i'm like
i think like you could tell like if
anything was like
violated or i don't know if like he
could have probably touched my tits i
wouldn't know
but damn that sucks though cause i i
just i just feel bad for him because his
wife isn't even on his side
that's the saddest that is the saddest
part because i'm just like dude
what happened like what's going on in
the wife's like mind where like
are you that insecure that your husband
may or may not be cheating on you or
like
that's because for the original poster
he's saying like in some of the comments
because people are like well we haven't
heard the the pooper's perspective like
how she feel about it and then so that's
when he added that
second part about how embarrassed she
was she left he apologized and they went
they're close too right they're close
friends the whole group's close she ends
up
like also writing in there that it seems
as if she's being like
like convinced to feel bad about this
situation
so she didn't in the beginning but now
like because everyone else is freaking
out about it now she's like oh [ __ ]
wait maybe i should freak out about it
because especially if the wife is in
that chat saying you should charge
it's just like implying to her like oh
[ __ ] did he ever have an interest in me
like am i in danger if i'm alone within
the room with him the wife can also be
very
susceptible to group minds so like if
the group
tells her to do like it just depends
some people are not
stern and strong and easily persuaded i
get it
but like you know if if like if i was in
that position right and then like let's
say you're the one that helped me clean
up my [ __ ] and then everybody here was
just like
oh like no that's not right right
especially somebody who's like closest
to you like if bar were to say that's
not right
i'll be like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna listen to
bart because he knows you the best
oh no like so he has that credibility so
then the wife
might be making it worse by not standing
up for him yeah
well yeah by also saying like you should
have had me do it where it's like girl
do you remember your state last night
like come on
like it was not it's it's wiping [ __ ]
and he's a nurse it's wiping [ __ ] like
when is
that ever a desirable thing i would say
if i was ever in that position i'll be
very thankful to you guys
right i'll be very thankful and then
she's not like thanks for letting me
be drunk and go to sleep and i don't
have to take care of [ __ ]
she actually said you should have woke
me up to clean this [ __ ] dookie
which really makes me wonder though like
if he's telling the whole story he said
yeah exactly like
what are we missing here that would make
them all react like yeah
yep what's the sh because people always
tell it tell stories in a way where
they're the hero
you just don't know either that the wife
was just like hella offended and and
like
embarrassed because she was like oh [ __ ]
i didn't do a duty of being a good
friend of duty
yeah duty and i'm just gonna put it on
my husband make him seem like the bad
guy i want to know
worse i just want to know their
background
maybe subconsciously maybe just well
okay
whatever my point is i would be the wife
and i just like i'm sorry i didn't do it
myself
like but i'm glad my nurse husband
was compassionate to wipe your [ __ ] i
would just say can we have a do-over
please so you're gonna [ __ ] yourself
again tonight
and the wife will re-correct this whole
thing please
because apparently the first time is no
good that's [ __ ] funny yeah now you
know
you did you got an [ __ ] but don't
wipe her [ __ ] again
[Music]
do
[Music]
you